good morning Hank it's Tuesday I know
that blank wall bothers you I just can't
think of what to do with it you can move
the camera over here there's too much
light I guess I could just zoom in but
then my face looks weird
I could do this angle this is a nice
angle for me but it's a little nostril
II yeah you know what I think I'm just
gonna go to the airport I know how to
make videos there and here we are Hank I
got to tell you my boundless enthusiasm
for airports it's a little bounded at
the moment by the way Hank if you
haven't noticed I have completely
stopped caring with the people in the
airport think of me I live here now this
is my residence so ain't the question
I'm asked most often these days is will
the Paper Towns movie be like the book
only I don't think they're saying it
like that exactly I think they're saying
it more like will the Paper Towns movie
be exactly like the book or if that's
how I hear it in my head the answer is
yes the Paper Towns movie is like the
book but but also it you know no it
isn't so like when I was a kid I was
really into novelizations books that
were adapted from TV's or movies I liked
I was particularly into the Goonies
novelization for those of you who
haven't been blessed by the magic of the
Goonies it was a movie about a bunch of
kids who to save their home kind of like
discover a pirate ship it's awesome and
the thing I love so much about reading
The Goonies novelization was that it was
like watching the movie in the sense
that all the stuff that happened in the
movie happened inside my head but the
novelization felt like fresh and
exciting and new in a way that the movie
couldn't because I'd already seen it
like a gajillion times so because I knew
the movie so well I noticed all the
little changes in the novelization like
the novel is written from the
first-person point of view of one kid
and that necessitated like some moving
around of stuff and some changes in
dialogue and Hank I loved that I loved
trying to figure out why the writer had
made changes to the movie in order to
make the story work as text images and
sound just kind of work on us
differently than text us like one of the
things I love about text-based stories
is that we sort of make them up with the
writer because the images that are
described in the text only exist inside
of my head while I'm reading like Hank
my Harry Potter is different from your
Harry Potter and every other Harry
Potter on the planet my Harry Potter is
just mine but anyway what I really want
from an adaptation is to feel the
feelings I felt while reading the book
right and personally I'm willing to
sacrifice a lot of plot points to make
that happen like when I wrote my own
screenplay of Paper Towns many years ago
it was vastly different from the book
like you ends up chasing after a
different girl also there was an
airplane crash it was just bananas
anyway all I wanted was to find a way to
visually tell the story that when you
put people on a pedestal when you fail
to imagine them complexly it's
tremendously destructive now it turns
out that relentlessly focusing on theme
instead of storytelling is a bad
strategy which is why that screenplay
was so horrible but the paper town
script at Mike Weber and Scott
Neustadter wrote the same guys who wrote
The Fault in Our Stars screenplay is
just brilliant because it finds a way to
capture both the story and the ideas at
least for me when I watched it the story
created the same feelings and the
characters had the same relationships
with each other and the same failures to
imagine each other and also Santa
complexly that said Hank if you look for
differences you'll definitely find lots
of them like for instance there's no
SeaWorld in the movie because no one was
anxious to pay SeaWorld for the chance
to give them good publicity
instead the stuff that happens at
SeaWorld in the book happens elsewhere
in the movie also there's significantly
less textual analysis of Walt Whitman in
the movie which I'm sure will be
disappointing to many don't worry
there's still some though also there are
some changes that I think are just
better like in the movie the character
Angela joins in on a road trip that she
isn't part of in the book and I like
that decision I wish I'd made it eight
years ago and that's another thing I've
learned from the Goonies novelization
Hank changes are not necessarily for the
worse in the end I'd rather have Paper
Towns be good than be faithful but I
genuinely believe that is both so I'm
just very grateful to the people who
made it I feel very lucky Hank your tour
is done congratulations I hope you sleep
for like three straight days and then I
hope you wake up because you have to
make a video on Friday I'll see you then